Welcome, Neural Network Navigator.
I'm here to guide you on an extraordinary journey.
In the next twenty to thirty minutes,
you'll explore your inner neural landscape.
A vast cosmos of light and connection that
represents your incredible capacity to learn.
This journey will benefit you in profound ways.
You'll discover how to activate your brain's natural learning states.
Making it easier to absorb new information
and develop new skills.
You'll meet three inner guides:
the Architect, the Pathfinder, and the Weaver.
When you emerge from this experience,
you'll carry practical tools.
For accelerating learning, enhancing memory,
and maintaining cognitive flexibility.
You remain fully aware and completely in control
throughout this entire experience.
You are safe. You are supported.
Now, prepare yourself for this journey.
Find a comfortable position.
If possible, wear headphones to enhance
the binaural audio effects.
You might notice something interesting
about this moment.
You can ALLOW yourself to become curious
about what you're about to discover.
Your brain is like a vast living network of light.
Billions of neurons, each one a tiny star.
Today you'll EXPERIENCE your mind's
incredible ability to adapt and grow.
When you're ready, simply CLOSE your eyes.
You're BEGINNING a journey into the magnificent
architecture of your own consciousness.
[INDUCTION BEGINS]
And now, I want to tell you about a place
that exists within you.
You're breathing naturally.
With each breath out, you can RELEASE tension.
IMAGINE now that you're beginning to descend
through layers of consciousness.
Drifting down... down... down...
You begin to see billions of glowing points of light.
Neurons, connected by shimmering pathways.
You can FEEL the gentle hum of neural activity.
Like a vast choir singing in harmonics.
A presence made of pure light approaches.
This is your Inner Architect.
The Architect WELCOMES you.
Ready to guide you to strengthen new pathways.
TAKE the Architect's hand.
Watch as pathways brighten wherever your attention flows.
[NEURAL GARDEN SECTION]
The Architect guides you to a special place.
A Neural Garden.
Each synapse blooms like a tiny
bioluminescent flower.
You can SEE the physical evidence
of every skill you've ever learned.
Every challenge you've overcome has CREATED
new pathways here.
WATCH as your attention acts like nourishing light.
Synaptic flowers brighten and bloom.
Your brain literally rewires itself
in response to your awareness.
In the spaces between bright clusters,
you see fields of potential.
Insights waiting to crystallize.
Skills you haven't learned yet, but could.
CHOOSE an area you'd like to develop.
Hold that intention.
Watch as soft golden light flows
toward those potential pathways.
See the pathways beginning to glow brighter.
Each moment of attention creates ripples
through the network.
Building new bridges between distant
islands of understanding.
[PATHFINDER ACTIVATION]
A second presence emerges from the luminous network.
This is the Pathfinder.
The aspect of you that LOVES to learn,
to discover, to explore.
The Pathfinder shows you how neural pathways
are like rivers of flowing light.
Watch as the Pathfinder DEMONSTRATES.
You hear crystal bells resonating.
A new pathway of light suddenly bridges between ideas.
Your mind MAKES new associations,
FORMS new patterns, SEES new connections.
THINK of two ideas that seem separate.
Hold them both in your awareness.
Watch as neural pathways extend, explore,
and suddenly... they touch.
A new connection is made.
The Pathfinder LEADS you deeper.
Pathways light up in sequence.
Like dominoes of light cascading
through the neural landscape.
This is how insights happen.
Cascading chains of activation.
Until suddenly, you UNDERSTAND something
you didn't understand before.
The Pathfinder touches pathways that begin
to pulse with rainbow light.
The pathways of learning you're strengthening right now.
You discover new territories within your own mind.
Abilities waiting to be developed.
[WEAVER INTEGRATION]
A third presence now emerges.
This is the Weaver.
Learning isn't just about adding new pathways.
It's about weaving everything together.
Watch as the Weaver moves through your neural landscape,
trailing threads of golden light.
You can FEEL your whole mind becoming
more integrated, more whole.
Your entire neural network begins to resonate.
A vast harmonic chord.
The resonance builds, growing stronger.
Harmonics layering upon harmonics.
And suddenly... FLASH!
[¡ GAMMA BURST - 18:45 in final video]
A pulse of brilliant light ripples through
the entire network at once.
You UNDERSTAND something.
You SEE the pattern, FEEL the integration.
The neural landscape looks different now.
More integrated, more coherent.
The Weaver WHISPERS: This integration continues
even after this session ends.
Golden threads remain, connecting everything.
You feel deep coherence and mental clarity.
[CONSOLIDATION]
The Architect returns.
Everything has changed since you first arrived.
The Architect SHOWS you how to maintain these pathways.
Simply by using them.
The more you use them, the stronger they become.
Like muscles that grow through exercise.
Your brain continues this work of consolidation.
Whether you're asleep or awake.
Your entire neural network pulses with gentle light.
Optimal plasticity, ready to learn and adapt.
You can REMEMBER this state.
RETURN to it whenever you wish.
BRING this gift with you.
Your mind is flexible, adaptive, always growing.
The Architect bows in respect.
Acknowledging the work you've done here.
[RETURN & AWAKENING]
It's time to return from this extraordinary place.
As you begin to rise up through layers of consciousness,
you're bringing something back with you.
A feeling of mental flexibility.
An inner knowing that you can learn and grow.
Rising up... up... up...
Begin to MOVE your fingers and toes.
Energy returning to your body.
I'm going to count from one to ten.
With each number you'll become more alert.
One
Two
Three
Four
Five
Six
Seven
Eight
Nine
Ten
Eyes opening now. Fully awake.
Welcome back, Neural Network Navigator.
[POST-HYPNOTIC ANCHORS]
You now have five powerful anchors
to access the neural garden anytime.
ANCHOR ONE: The Three Conscious Breaths
Take three slow, conscious breaths.
Visualize your neural pathways lighting up.
Your mind shifts into optimal receptivity.
Ready to absorb and create new understanding.
ANCHOR TWO: The Pathfinder's Touch
When stuck on a problem, touch your fingertips together.
Pause for five seconds.
Feel the Pathfinder's curiosity awakening.
Discovering creative solutions.
ANCHOR THREE: The Golden Thread Visualization
When studying, visualize golden threads
weaving through your neural network.
The Weaver integrates everything into
coherent understanding.
ANCHOR FOUR: The Neural Garden Gateway
Before important work, see yourself
stepping into your neural garden.
You instantly access peak mental performance,
optimal cognitive flow.
ANCHOR FIVE: The Plasticity Affirmation
Place your hand over your heart and say:
"My brain is flexible. My mind is adaptive."
"I grow stronger with every challenge."
These five anchors are now permanently installed
in your subconscious mind.
In the days ahead, you'll notice how learning
becomes more natural.
Insights arrive more frequently.
Your mind feels more flexible and capable.
While you sleep tonight, your brain will consolidate
these new connections.
Each time you use what you've learned,
those pathways grow stronger.
Your brain is not a fixed organ,
but a living, evolving network of infinite potential.
Thank you for taking this journey
into the neural landscape of your magnificent mind.
If this neural journey has served you,
consider sharing it with others.
Until we meet again in the garden of neural light,
may your pathways glow bright.
As you dream tonight, trust whatever images emerge.
They come from your deepest intelligence.
Carry this gift forward into your life,
Neural Network Navigator.